to defeat your enemy you have to
understand them
there's always a bit of truth in legends
the Empire's making our travels around
the outer rim tougher all the time
everywhere we go we run into those guys
this keeps up we'll never be able to
help the rebels establish a base senator
Organa heard about our losses he's
sending us reinforcements
cham syndulla at your service get down
you're a princess you don't have to risk
your life doing this I feel like because
I can fight I have to for those who
cannot and I think you might be the same
way
you Jedi are growing in their power
it will be their undoing my gut tells me
this is a trap
is it wrong for me to fight for me to
protect my friends
how did I choose to win the question is
growing your abilities are
and with them
he's amazing you should have seen him in
person
he was my master
the dark side it pulls at him
it calls to him
you see knowledge call me old master
you win by surviving
I hate it when she says that
as we docked
ahsoka why don't you leave do you know
what
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so I wanted to
do a rebels trailer video just because
it looks like they're combining a lot of
classic loora loora from the EU about
Jedi with new force awakens Jedi lore so
it looks like it's gonna be a lot of fun
biggest new stuff right away
Princess Leia Yoda and what looks like a
death of Morean Sith Lord I don't know
if he senses a thought or not but this
looks like a Sith temple this looks like
a Sith holocron so I'm assuming that
this person is associated with that but
I think there was some confusion a lot
of people thought that he might be
supreme leader snoke know if you look at
the shadow you could see the face
tattoos he looks just like Darth Maul it
sounds like it could be Darth Maul sam
witwer is the guy who voiced Darth Maul
for the Clone Wars he could be back he
voiced Emperor Palpatine for Star Wars
Battlefront so if he can voice the
Emperor he could probably an older
version of Darth Maul who becomes this
Dark Master but just to be clear I
haven't seen any official confirmation
on Darth Maul so all we know is that
this is another son of Dathomir that
opening line of dialogue is from ahsoka
she says to defeat your enemy you have
to understand them as you can see rebels
is just positing that Ezra might be on a
similar trajectory to Anakin he talks to
a souca about Anakin you should have
seen him in person he was my master
probably my favorite light from the
trailer though is when Vader is
confronting ahsoka and you hear the
voice of Anakin ahsoka why did you leave
do you know what I've become you have to
remember that this is still season two
this is just the second half of season
two at the beginning of season two they
introduced the Vader character to the
series the Sokka came out she did not
know that Vader was Anakin Skywalker
till the end of that first episode so be
sure to go back and watch it if you
don't remember you might be wondering
about these other Jedi here this just
looks like another sect of Jedi it's a
little confusing the way episode 7 is
treating light side and dark side force
users like are there Jedi are there Sith
are there other factions that we don't
know about I'm guessing that the Knights
of Ren is just another faction that
we're gonna learn about so this just
like that is like a light side faction
on the other side of that coin I always
get a lot of questions about what's
canon now the Clone Wars is still canon
rebels is canon so anything they deal
with in the series any characters that
introduced also exists in the movies
even if the movies never address it
there's like a whole lot of stuff that
the movies will never have time to
address most of the other big questions
from
I mean it's just jam-packed with like
all the biggest action sequences from
the next couple of episodes but there's
the cross guard saber which looks like
kylo ren's but it looks like a working
version of kylo ren's like kylo Ren is a
DIY lightsaber enthusiast but he's just
not that great at it yet so this is
probably also built on a Kyber crystal
probably super powerful so understand
more about this classic design because
kylo Ren did build an ancient design to
use his lightsaber but the reason for
the vents on his lightsaber are because
the blade can't contain the energy the
Kyber crystal and his saber is cracked I
don't know if that's the same case with
Ezra's lightsaber that he's holding here
just look at all the lightsabers in this
trailer it looks like Oprah showed up
and was just like you get a lightsaber
you get a lightsaber you get a
lightsaber because it's a show for young
kids they really want the sensational
stuff little kids love lightsabers so of
course there's gonna be lightsabers
everywhere
I feel like Star Wars rebels is a good
show at its core but a lot of people get
turned off with this over simplistic
dialogue some of it's really easy to
follow plots it deals with some really
interesting ideas but because the show
is written for little children sometimes
they can throw you off a little let me
know in the comments like what are you
really excited about after watching this
trailer and what do you think about Star
Wars rebels do you think it's getting
more exciting now that it's in season
two I felt like it was really slow in
season 1 I tried to start doing videos
but I just couldn't stay interested so I
come back every once in a while usually
like I'll wait a couple weeks and then
I'll catch up on episodes so I am
totally open to doing rebels videos but
I'm probably not gonna do them every
single week probably an explainer video
if they do something really cool about
Jedi lore or they introduce some really
new idea but basically what they're
doing is is having a little bit of fun
with the new Canon the New Jedi lore
while also invoking a lot of classic
things that'll be really familiar if
you're a big fan of the EU so much
awesome comic book stuff happening in
the next week or so while you guys wait
for all that stuff to post you can click
here to learn all about what's going on
with episodes 8 and 9 the producers have
already started to tease some big stuff
and you can click here to learn all
about the Captain America special that's
happening next week thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
and I'll see you guys tonight
you